vamos a extender ahora nuestro
conocimiento sobre el cálculo a la
tercera dimensión y antes que nada vamos
a ver cómo se ve una función en tres
dimensiones de hecho vamos a ver que hay
distintos tipos de funciones podemos
tener una línea una curva pues o una
superficie o un campo vectorial hay
muchas representaciones por ejemplo
cuando empezamos a trabajar no se
podemos empezar a trabajar con algo que
yo creo que es muy intuitivo que son las
superficies al menos para mí las
superficies en tres dimensiones son lo
más fácil de ver primero y después
podemos extender nuestro concepto en
otro tipo de funciones así que pongamos
nuestros tradicionales xy pero además
vamos a agregar otra dimensión que es el
de la altura digamos que este es mi eje
x ok y este es el eje y y ahora ponemos
una altura que es el eje z y el
procedimiento convencional es seguir la
regla de la mano derecha en donde el eje
x bueno tomando el producto cruz del eje
x con el eje y es igual al eje z lo que
quiero decir con esto es
que en realidad okay estos colores no no
sé si son agradables a la vista pero
bueno si tenemos nuestro vector unitario
en la dirección x le ponemos de nombre y
ahora tomamos nuestro vector unitario en
la dirección ya que lo vamos a llamar j
roots está con el sombrerito entonces
todos este i y j tienen una magnitud de
1 también tendremos un vector unitario
en la dirección zeta que le llamamos k
entonces por convención el producto cruz
o el producto vectorial de y con jota y
cruz jota será igual acá y esto es sólo
una convención para dibujar el eje x
apuntando en esta dirección que por
supuesto también pensamos que se se
extienden en el sentido opuesto verdad
esto va en la dirección de iu
y tratando de asegurar que mi mano lo
haga bien déjenme dibujar el producto
cruz con con la mano entonces si tomamos
el primer vector ese se lo ponemos al
dedo índice después el segundo vector el
vector j lo pondremos en el dedo de en
medio ya después pintamos los otros
deditos de la mano y entonces este dedo
índice dijimos va en dirección del
vector y y éste va en dirección del
vector k no perdón del vector cano pj
verdad del vector j entonces el pulgar
que apunta hacia arriba en esta
dirección apunta en la dirección de acá
muy bien entonces esta es una buena
forma de saber cuál es la convención y
este es lo que llamamos un sistema de
coordenadas bueno ahora sí vamos a lo
importante como definimos una superficie
en tres dimensiones pues definimos z
como una función de x y de g
así que hagámoslo en nuestra notación
zeta es igual a una función que depende
ahora de dos variables xy de g
lo que quiere decir es que si yo te doy
un valor de x y un valor de y puedes
sacar un valor de zeta
de manera que escojamos 1
por ejemplo z es igual a digamos que
podemos poner digamos x cuadrada más
bien ok entonces como representamos
estos puntos en una superficie lo que
hacemos es asignarle constantes a esta
altura en cada punto del plano verdad
entonces
vamos a seguir aquí z no digamos que f
de 21 no sé si de 21
ok vamos a evaluar la función en el
punto 21 pues esto quiere decir que hay
que elevar al cuadrado a 2 y sumarle 1
es decir esto nos da 5 y si tuviéramos
que graficar este punto en la superficie
digamos nos vamos dos unidades en la
dirección x y una unidad en la dirección
y entonces tenemos este punto en el
plano xy verdad y después decimos que 7
es igual a 5 entonces vamos hacia arriba
5 unidades y hemos graficado el punto de
esta gráfica verdad
entonces si juntamos todos tendremos una
superficie
la pregunta natural que puedes tener es
de hecho de déjenme mostrarles una
superficie
temo que la computadora se ponga un poco
lenta debido a esto pero bueno correr el
riesgo
sigan conmigo en el ejercicio aquí está
la superficie que usó la la obtuve del
java applet rafer que de hecho es gratis
luego les paso el link pero bueno en
esta es la gráfica de la función no se
preocupen ahorita por esta esta pared
que vemos ahí pero ésta cazuelita es una
función que depende de xy de y aquí
están los ejes y la altura es el eje z
esto realmente espero no hagan lenta mi
computadora pero de hecho podemos rotar
esta gráfica miren
miren nada más
ya lo aprecian mejor no quiero alentar
la computadora mientras trato de hacer
este tipo de rotaciones en fin de
cualquier modo entenderás que donde
tomas primero un punto x luego un punto
y entonces un punto z en estas
superficies y en ese plano que lo está
intersectando esta superficie de aquí es
una función o la gráfica de una función
de xy de y ahora la pregunta es cómo
aplicamos el cálculo a las superficies
porque ok déjenme poner de nuevo esta
gráfica porque si miramos la superficie
y tuviéramos que elegir un punto al azar
y decir cuál es la pendiente de este
punto bueno ya no tiene mucho
significado porque tienes que decidir
una dirección si dices cuál es la
pendiente pues de una recta tangente
pues tiene una infinidad de rectas
tangentes no toma un tazón o algo que se
le parezca y luego no sé un palillo o
algo así
entonces coloque el palillo tangente al
tazón y como puedes ver en cualquier
punto del tazón puede rotar el palillo
entonces tienes que elegir la
orientación del palillo
lo que vamos a aprender es que cuando
tomas una derivada en tres dimensiones
tienes que especificar la dirección en
la que quieres tomarla por esa razón
dibuje esta pared aquí esta pared es
igual a la ecuación de igual a punto 3
entonces puedes ver que a lo largo de
esta pared y es constante verdad
entonces si asumimos que ya es constante
podríamos simplemente tomar la derivada
con respecto a x y esencialmente saber
la pendiente de esta curva de aquí la
curva de la intersección bueno primero
que nada
cuál es la ecuación de esta superficie
está realmente la encontré en la
wikipedia pero la ecuación de la
superficie voy a quitar esto porque
si no me estorba mucho
vamos a borrar todo de nuevo porque
seguramente necesitaremos más espacio
entonces de regreso a la herramienta de
la pluma la ecuación zeta es igual a x
cuadrada más xy más y al cuadrado muy
bien de manera que si dijéramos que
queremos obtener la derivada es fácil
porque no puedes no es fácil porque no
puedes decir que hay una sola dirección
tenemos que elegir una sola variable y a
eso derivarlo ahora a eso que hacemos es
una derivada parcial en realidad no es
más difícil que realizar una derivada
como ya las conocemos solo que una de
las variables va a permanecer constante
ahora queremos saber para cualquier
constante
cuál es la pendiente o la derivada
respecto a x entonces tomamos la
derivada parcial de zeta
respecto a x que es notación ok es como
una de pero pero como ry sarita entonces
la parcial de zeta respecto de x ésta es
la anotación lo único que hacemos es
derivar la expresión de zeta respecto de
x y asumir que ya es constante
así que la derivada de x cuadradas 2x y
la derivada de xy pues siendo una
constante es sólo un número es una
constante pues entonces ya simplemente
sale de la derivada verdad así que esto
nos queda simplemente ya porque la
derivada de x es 1 ahora cuál es la
derivada de ye cuadrada respecto a x
como ye cuadrada es una constante en
este caso la derivada de una constante
es cero verdad así que la derivada de ye
cuadrada respecto a x s ahora la p la
derivada parcial de zeta respecto a x es
esta expresión 2x más bien y qué
significa todo esto
esto significa que si fuéramos y de
hecho déjenme hacer una pequeña
anotación antes y que es otra manera de
escribir esto es lo siguiente
fx
es igual a equis cuadrada más xy más
cuadrada ok y entonces lo que hacemos es
tomar la derivada parcial de f respecto
a x simplemente lo ponemos como f sub x
ok como subíndice y por supuesto hay que
decir en qué punto le evaluamos ok
entonces esto va a ser igual también a
12 x +
de cualquier modo pensé que era
conveniente que viera la anotación ahora
que significa que la pendiente de z
respecto a x de hecho vamos a escoger
números pequeños por ejemplo x igual a 1
ok no no sé x igual a 0.2 y igual a un
0.36 0.3 ok bueno podemos utilizar esto
y decir la derivada parcial de f
respecto a x
el punto cero punto 2.3
es igual a 2 veces x que es punto 2.3
entonces tenemos que la derivada parcial
de f respecto de x en este punto que
elegimos es igual a punto 7 ahora veamos
si podemos visualizar esto regresamos a
nuestra gráfica muy bien entonces esta
pared representa la línea de igual a
punto 3 y queremos la pendiente cuando x
es igual a punto 2 así que este es x
igual a punto 2 la razón de cambio
respecto de x en este punto es punto 7
de manera que cada vez que x se
incrementa z incrementará punto 7 así
que la pendiente es un poco menos que
una verdad la tangente aquí incrementa
con mientras aumentan los valores de x
de cualquier manera y acabamos se me
acaba el tiempo nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo